ukraine's low-level conflict marked by
sporadic violence in the east came under
focus in parliament during plenary this
after Moscow announced a visa ban for
19m eps this is not only disrespect to
the european parliament but an insult to
the EU as a whole hefty majority passed
a resolution calling for EU unity in the
face of russian aggression and demanding
countermeasures against Kremlin
propaganda Putin has to change that's it
it is right that Russia was excluded
from the g7 meeting this week because
it's politicians and people need to
understand that if you break
international law you cannot expect to
contribute to international law making
there was support for Moscow from the
far right but more still across the
groups for a measured rapprochement when
the time is right until then sanctions
should remain says the mep steering the
resolution preconditions first
incentives later we are hearing from
ukraine that there are still flow of
weapons the body's not control so i say
that missed agreements are not being
helped the question now whether europe
stands firm that will become clear
during a summer to be you heads later in
june before they're due to decide on the
sanctions regime